gremlins is basically a Christmas
monster movie something which might seem
surprising it for his glance but in
looking at the basic elements of the
story we find in it an inner coherence
of analogies which is not only
surprising for a movie which appears so
campy it for his glance but this web of
meaning can maybe even help us
understand the meaning of Christmas and
how it connects to personal and cosmic
symbolism especially the manner in which
the time of the winter solstice can be
represented as a descent into chaos
darkness as the breakdown of meaning and
then finally the sunrise this surprise
of a new Sun coming to chase away the
night
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
the gremlin story begins as mr. Peltzer
the father of the main character Billy
is exploring a foreign area it's only
Chinatown but it's made to look like a
place of wander and strangeness he
descends into a cave of treasures to
encounter a Chinese man who is the
guardian of a Mogwai which is the
mandarin word for monster the Mogwai
just like the foreigner is this
encounter with something that is unknown
a challenge to the normal categories of
existence just like the foreign or any
other novelty and exercises fascination
courtesan but because it is unknown it
also bears the danger of destroying the
established order much responsibility
the name given to the monster gizmo
reflects this notion of a novel yet
unknown thing here the unknown is also
related to the illegitimate as mr.
Peltzer acquires the Mogwai knowing the
old chinese man did not want to sell it
to him when mr. Pell's to receive the
Mogwai he's given three rules which will
be of prime importance do not expose it
to light or it will die do not expose it
to water and especially never feed it
after midnight just as the holiday
season is also the time of the Solstice
we can understand the entire story as a
descent into darkness the movie shows us
a series of places where the vehicles of
order are pathological and distorted
where things are not working as they
should we see the authority of police is
non-functional and corrupt the bank
supervisor has abusive and condescending
I would have fired you in a second
the user miss deagle who's a literal
Scrooge the bank and I have the same
purpose in life to make money not to
support a lot of deadbeat we also
encounter the nationalism and xenophobia
of Marie Futterman who complains about
for technology and dreams of a time when
people bought American damn foreign cars
of course the ultimate version of this
problem in the normal order of things is
mr. Peltier himself a failed inventor
although he's constantly inventing new
things his inventions fail and therefore
show him incapable of adequately
providing for the future mr. peltor
boasts fantastic ideas for a fantastic
world I make the hill logical logical
but it is precisely his failure to do so
which will bring in a period of chaos
and since mr. Peltzer cannot support his
family this task has fallen to his son
Billy and it is in this way that the
corruption of the normal order is also
shown as an inversion the world is about
to be turned upside down and this is
shown by Billy placing his nametag
upside down on his Bank desk in cosmic
terms the failure of the father is
precisely the yearly experience of the
son getting lower and lower in the sky
the day is getting shorter as the
Solstice approaches darkness is rising
and we fear that the darkness will
prevail that the light might disappear
forever the movie this is shown by the
eruption of the gremlins into the town
of course but in terms of the imagery of
the father we also see it in two
instances first we find mr. Peltzer
leaving his family for Christmas which
is symbolically equivalent to the
Solstice but more explicitly this
descent of the sun's light is best
resumed by the story told by Kate where
she speaks of her father dressing up as
Santa Claus as father Christmas and
wanting to surprise them by coming down
the chimney Santa Claus coming down the
dark chimney and exiting in the fire pit
where the fire is kindled is precisely
the image of the Sun going down into
darkness and being reborn real it for
the new year but here the father gets
stucked in the descent and the darkness
prevails changing Christmas not into the
celebration of birth but the experience
of death it is precisely this duality
that Christmas has always been concerned
with with the divine logos the origin of
all meaning being born in a dark cave
framed by the rise of a foreign
Empire and the massacre of innocent
children all killed in the hope of
snuffing out this new light this new
king in the movie though the dark
potential this monster is not bad in
itself at least not at the outset
because Moore appears rather as benign
and charming attractive by it's
fascinating strangeness just like
novelty in general or the experience of
the strange and foreign it is rather
when the rules of proper hospitality are
broken that all hell breaks loose
gizmo's malleable you can be influenced
for good or for ill and in that sense he
has the capacity to be integrated into
normal order tamed if you will this
image is especially reinforced in the
scene where gizmo is shown sporting the
American flag showing gizmo as the
integrated foreigner the other Mogwai on
the other hand those that erupt from
gizmo are not so benign they're
mischievous destructive and are looking
to propagate and increase their power
not as integrated exceptions but akin to
a foreign invasion a good way to
understand the other Mogwai is to look
at the structure on a personal level
imagine you as a person have these
desires on the edge of your being these
thoughts and potential actions within
you a basic desire like the one for food
or for sex or for pleasure in general is
not bad in itself if properly regulated
such desires can be good in fact but if
breaking the rules given you plunge them
into water which is this image of chaos
and potentiality itself and let them
multiply if you feed them after midnight
in the dark place where light and order
are in their lowest moments then you
will produce vices in your life that
will take over and destroy you just like
the gremlins started to destroy the city
giving it to impulse and desire is shown
as the regression from the mammalian to
the reptilian brain in the movie this is
why the scene in the bar is one of the
best and where we discover the more
pagan influence visible in the gremlins
movie you see the Winter Solstice in
ancient times what was also Saturnalia
the moment in the year were all the
structures all the morality all the
taboos of a society were turned upside
was a festival and inversion the bar
scene we see the result of the rule of
darkness where all the tropes of human
vices are caricatures and put into one
gigantic chaotic and orgiastic event
first of all we have this giving in to
leisure games dancing drinking smoking
eating but ultimately rowdiness violence
gambling and perversion theft murder all
mashed together until Cate discovers
that the darkness can only be chased
away by life that is how we come to the
third rule not to expose the creature to
light the Mogwai and especially the
gremlins are this dark potential chaos
the unknown the undetermined the
imaginary the nightmare this is why the
first casualty of their appearance is
the scientist and they represent exactly
that place that is not yet tamed and
contained wearying dark things to light
is precisely how they are destroyed by
naming framing them properly doing
exactly what mr. Peltzer said he was
meant to do making the illogical logical
that's how these dark things are tamed
and their wildness vanishes this is why
Kate not only uses fire in the bar scene
but also uses a camera most casting
light on the gremlins but also
documenting them at the same time now
although the coming of the gremlins is
excessively destructive it's also a
strange kind of cleansing the gremlins
embody all the chaos but this chaos acts
as a flood to cleanse the city and so
all the images of Pathology mr.
Futterman mrs. deagle the policemen are
destroyed in this dark transition
[Music]
in order to understand the coherence of
the final scenes where the gremlins are
finally destroyed when needs to first to
ponder the relationship between gremlins
and Technology
gremlins are the rarest of things they
are a modern monster their legend
appeared in world war ii as a
personification of accidents of
breakdowns in technology in aircrafts
and machinery in general they were
playfully represented as one of the
enemies to face in the war efforts
technology is always a kind of war not
necessarily a war against other people
but also a war against the dangers of
the natural world in general using the
potentiality of nature to defend us
against nature a supplement to protect
us make us more powerful and make us
less vulnerable to the cold to the
darkness to disease to our own human
limitations in general and ultimately to
our political enemies in the form of
weapons and that manner the monstrous
Mogwai can be seen as the potentiality
of the natural world itself a
potentiality which can both destroy us
but can also be focused tamed and
channeled towards a greater defense
against the dangers of that natural
world itself this is of course where the
Chinese man tells us at the end that the
Mogwai represent the very force of
nature itself and that the Americans are
not ready to gain the keys to that that
they are acting in ears in an
irresponsible manner I've explored the
duality of Technology in other videos
but technology both makes us powerful
while also making us more vulnerable our
very lives are dependent on the smooth
functioning of our vehicles our
electrical systems our appliances
technology is therefore a paradox and
this paradoxes is explored fully in the
movie if the deaths of the bad apples in
the movie are attributed to technology
turning against its user in a time of
chaos and the death of mrs. deagle the
police offers mr. Futterman
it is the very fact that gizmo is
malleable and can be influenced that
makes them not only the source of the
gremlins but also the solution to the
grounds as well just as the gremlins
killed others by a breakdown in the
normal functioning of Technology gizmo
operates a last in
version or by losing control of a toy
car he finds himself at the right place
and finally end the long night reignites
the fire at the lowest moment of the
solstice and lets the sunlight enter the
story once again the return of the Sun
the restoration of balance is also the
return to the pristine natural world
represented by the garden setting in the
final scene as the gremlin melts away
into formless chaos the father also
returns with the sunlight reinforcing
the entire structure and pattern of the
movie of course the return of the Sun
happens in the film on Christmas morning
so all of the imagery ties well with how
the birth of the Christ child is seen by
Christians as the dawn of a new era its
although as a Christmas movie gremlins
might seem like an affront to the
celebration of Christmas we find that it
also follows in a strained way the very
structure of the solstice and the
Christmas story as well and so I can
only say to everybody I wish you all a
very Merry Christmas
Christ is born so I hope you enjoyed my
interpretation of gremlins um I just
want to say this one might be my last
video of the year and so it's been a
great year and a lot of things have
happened in this year of course and I'm
also moving very quickly towards the
future I am getting I'm getting a I've
just gotten a new computer I'm getting a
new camera some new lighting a new
microphone and I've been really busy in
the fall so I haven't had time to pull
it all together but hopefully by the
beginning of next year at least sometime
in January the experience of the
symbolic world will be very different
and so that's all thanks to your support
I really appreciate all the support
that's been coming my way and hopefully
we can continue to make all these videos
better so once again have a Merry
Christmas Happy New Year and I will see
you all very soon
obviously Santa Claus exists
[Applause]
[Music]
obviously Santa Claus exists
[Applause]
you see Santa Claus exists